and I would say to people back in 1995
look if you don't understand the
internet you're not gonna be able to do
business and now that's just blocking
the tackling that seems obvious back
then it wasn't you're gonna have to have
at least if not more cursory
understanding of artificial intelligence
because it will change everything we do
and if the internet was 10x in terms of
change to business artificial
intelligence will be a hundred x or more
what's that belief nation it's seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so to help you on your
journey today we're gonna learn about
the rise of AI and how machine learning
will change the world enjoy I focus on
things that are AI driven artificial
intelligence driven whether it's machine
learning deep learning learning neural
networks medical applications but within
ai ai is a buzz word that everybody is
using right now you know every in and to
that point you know we as old guys we go
back and it's like 1995 we talk about
the internet and I would say to people
back in 1995 look if you don't
understand the internet you're not gonna
be able to do business and now that's
just blocking a tackle and it seems
obvious back then it wasn't right I
could even take you further back to my
first company you know what we did was a
company called micro solutions and we
did local area networks on wide area
networks and I used to walk into
companies and and say you're gonna have
to hook these pcs together at some point
that'll make you more productive more
effective you know give you a
competitive advantage and people are
like now I just carry this floppy from
this PC to that PC yeah okay but today
we're at the same type of inflection
point with artificial intelligence you
don't have to be an expert and be able
to put together your own neural network
you know you don't have to know what
weights and biases are but but you have
to have more than just a cursory
understanding just like you have to know
the difference between you know
different types of websites and you have
to under
and ecommerce if during the e-commerce
you have to have a cursory understanding
of how apps work you're gonna have to
have at least if not more cursory
understanding of artificial intelligence
because it will change everything we do
and if the internet was NX in terms of
change to business artificial
intelligence will be 100x or more now
what what does artificial intelligence
mean and how does it impact your
business in the past we you know you put
together a little business plan and you
put together a spreadsheet and then
you'd figure it out
what's the number I have to get to right
and you do what if what if would have
what if what if what if what if what if
with but and you might even have two or
three people's working with you or I'll
sit and talk with Bart and it'd be like
well try something different and you get
the benefit of two people or three
people or five people throwing ideas
that you to say what if this and so
that's good but with artificial
intelligence not only does it does it
take the what ifs that you enter in and
create and then the things that you
label but it can it can figure out every
possible what-if combination now think
about that so with machine learning if I
want to know if something is gonna be
true or false or has a great probability
of this happening or that happening or
you know this is it can I categorize it
this way or that way is it gonna make
money lose money if you could have every
possible what-if scenario thought
through for you that'd be a good thing
right
that's what machine learning is starting
to do for businesses now now take it
even further when you put together that
spreadsheet and you're trying to think
of all the different coral combinations
you couldn't come up with every variable
there were going to be more they're
gonna be all kinds of things you left
out of your spreadsheet that you want to
go what-if with about what neural
networks do or deep learning if you want
to call it that probably more app it
starts coming up with more variables
that you didn't think of and then it
starts generalizing not only are there
there
these variables that you didn't think of
but there's all these other things you
didn't think of either and I'm gonna
give you some ideas how they can impact
your business it's crazy the types that
how fast it can go through all these
reiterations or iterations and come back
with information you never even consider
before that's why it's going to change
business and it's a simple example to
apply it within a spreadsheet realm or a
financial realm but the types of things
with video you know computer vision and
creating new ideas and new opportunities
you know I invested in a company called
Genesis and whatever what it's a medical
AAI based company and what it does every
organ in your body emits an electrical
signal and there are sensors now that
can pick up though that little tiny
electrical signal and there's one that
these guys license actually exclusively
that picks up that electrical signal
from your heart and they take the output
they pick up that signal you're just
there and then picks it up then it saves
it to an old-school wav file right just
an audio file but then it runs it
through a neural network and because
it's done it so many times now it can
tell you so right now any one of five
ailments that you may have heart
ailments that you may have with about a
98% accuracy which is far better than
any cardiologist or any doctor can ever
do that's just the start that's just one
example these are the things we're going
to see within every industry finance
medical and Albert you're active in it
there's not an industry that's not going
to be impacted your business is going to
be impacted I don't have to guess I'm
going to tell you with 100% certainty
your business is going to be impacted
it's going to impact the workforce and
jobs so there's going to be a disruption
and change in the types of jobs that's
going to impact your customers that's
going to impact your businesses
it's going to impact the future of
business and so I can't I don't want to
be you know I want to be as clear and as
forceful as I possibly can because as
fellow entrepreneurs we always have to
look for an edge we always have to
understand how our industry is changing
we always have to understand not only
how we differentiate ourselves and our
companies but you always I always want
to know who can kick my ass right and
all my businesses who can kick my ass
and can I kick my own ass first because
if you can disrupt yourself first you're
the person who could otherwise do it is
not going to do it and you can compete
and be successful so pay attention to AI
it's important if you go to my house
right next to my bed there's a book
machine learning for dummies you go into
my bathroom
there's even neural networks for dummies
right if you go home there's a something
for dummies in every room of my house
you know they could go two ways I know
but I'm just telling you put the time I
mean I've taken you know I can't even
tell you how many hours now I spent
every week if not daily working like
I'll go into Amazon AWS and go through
their machine learning tutorials don't
think to yourself I'm not technical
enough or I'm not gonna get this or I
don't get into this or it's too much try
it get as far as you can because it's
like doing a basic website and a little
bit of HTML just having done that you
feel smarter and you feel a little bit
more confident about this you know I
don't want to be an alarmist but I'm
trying to scare the hell out of you
because it's important thank you guys so
much for watching quick question today I
want to know what do you think about AI
are you using it in your business do you
know anything about it at all do you not
care are you terrified for the world let
me know your thoughts leave in the
comments below thank you again for
watching I believe in you I hope
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is much
loved see you soon
if you tell yourself a story long enough
you start to believe it won't you
believe it you act like I have a tussle
what a whale out of handcuffed lightning
though Thunder in jail now you know I'm
bad on the last week I murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between eighteen and two hundred
and fifty four days of taking action for
a new habit to stick I've created a new
course called 250 for confidence or
every single day for 254 days I will be
sending you a video between 30 seconds
and 5 minutes long that you start your
morning with around making you feel
confident it's absolutely free check out
the link in the description below to get
access